on the set I'm told that you had a bet
with Margot Robbie and the loser of that
bet had to get a tattoo first of all
what was the bet we had a bet about a
rugby game it's like an age-old rivalry
the state where I'm from New South Wales
plays the state was she's from
Queensland and yeah I think I foolishly
suggested that uh you know whoever came
out on top of the series was able to
tattoo the other person cuz she carries
around a tattoo gun so if you whoever
lost had to get a tattoo of their body
height that they weren't from of the
opposing team yeah who's got to be just
humiliated it was dumb I mean I sort of
neglected to remember that my timer at
the end of like a seven year losing
streak will see your odds were terrible
yeah and so I like Hamblin man yeah why
so I'm inked now yeah you lost I lost
and then you got a tattoo of the team
that you despised where is it on your
body it's on my wrist we see it right
now not much to look at but right a
little QLD there at the Queensland okay
right there Yeah right
and that's did she do that she did that
okay she's not good at that
sorry I'm just not gonna have her do my
text this time I think I will
you